l'événement était attendu par les
amateurs d'équitation pour la deuxième
année consécutive une compétition
internationale de concours complet était
organisée à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
l'événement s'est déroulé sur trois
jours du 2 au 4 octobre sur le plan
sportif le rendez-vous est passé cette
année de 2 à 3 étoiles
techniquement en fait c'est plus
difficile plus vous rajoutez d'étoilés
plus électriquement difficile donc ce
sont des cavaliers de haut niveau déjà
bien aguerri avec des chevaux beaucoup
plus aguerrie aussi qui courent sur ce
genre de parcours
parmi les 400 sportifs présents des
étrangers ainsi que des stars de la
discipline le cavalier international
nicolas touzaint champion olympique en
2004 à athènes a participé à trois
épreuves mais je suis venu ici déjà
parce que il ya un programme qui était
intéressant pour moi et pour mes chevaux
c'est la première fois que je viens et
on est toujours ravi de faire un nouveau
concours parce que c'est vrai qu'on fait
les mêmes tous les ans après ça se
répète et là le fait de venir sur un
nouveau site qu'on connaît pas c'est
toujours assez assez sympa une nouvelle
édition est déjà prévue pour l'année
prochaine les organisateurs imagine déjà
un cross avec plus de difficultés